now you know that we can't stop talking
about inflation because it affects our
daily life from where we live to what we
wear and of course to what we eat one
way brands are adjusting to the new norm
is through celebrity partnerships to
drum up business fast food chain crystal
just named two chains it's head of
creative marketing the rapper joins us
now alongside jonathan childs he's the
founder of golden child holdings one of
the primary investors in the brand thank
you both so much for being here today
two chains i'm gonna kick it off with
you you're obviously a busy guy you're
releasing a highly anticipated album
next week and you're now the head of
creative marketing for a huge fast food
chain which sounds like a job that my
friends would apply for on linkedin what
attracted you to this opportunity well
honestly i'm i'm looking forward to
what's next i feel like i am one of the
um
upper echelons when it comes to
marketing and thinking outside of the
box and being creative and
i met jonathan through a you know mutual
friend we're both georgia boys and
crystal is such an identifiable and a
credible brand that i just felt like uh
it was a challenge that i wanted to
accept
and jonathan going to you we've seen
more and more brands partnering with
celebrities particularly for c-suite
positions do you think that this is a
trend that we're going to see kind of
becoming the new norm for businesses i
don't know if it's the new norm i think
it's a new trend um
i think what you're seeing a lot of is
is uh paid endorsements our deal with
chains is a little bit different it's a
true partnership i
i think though
with everybody using their phones more
and more frequently and and that's
really the channel for marketing these
days it makes sense
to to partner with uh celebrity types if
you will i think i think our like i said
i think our deal is a little bit
different part of the collaboration
right is two chains you are working on a
co-branded custom crystal restaurant in
the neighborhood you grew up in sounds
like the neighborhood you both grew up
in what is that gonna look like two
chains is it gonna have you know some
cool parts of your personality infused
into the restaurant do you have any fun
quirks that you can kind of break for us
here i do have tons of ideas that man
are really out of this world
and um so it's like you know i'm having
my own store to start this off and and
from then you know who knows maybe four
or five stores but you know like i said
crystal is a brand that's been around
forever and it's it's my job to you know
put the cool back and bring the cool
well and you're really good at that i
feel like you are one of the few
celebrities that's mastered branding and
you rebranded yourself before you
released your first mixtape
what was the biggest lesson that you
learned about branding back in 2011 when
you did the renaming
that you've kind of that's kind of stuck
with you that you remember and look back
on as like a good lesson on rebranding i
have you know people that are you know
entrepreneurs they're in
they're in the vc space they're in
different spaces
and
they rebrand
you know about you know every three
years or so
and i started taking a look at myself
and
started to move and think more like a
business although i am an individual and
that's what led to you know all the
stuff that you're seeing currently with
2chainz right that's really interesting
you saw it as a business opportunity to
continue to rebrand and it clearly
worked you've got over 10 million
instagram followers i mean what do you
think has allowed you to successfully
navigate those rebrands while kind of
keeping your authenticity keeping your
content authentic and continuing to
resonate with your existing fans
throughout your career i think the
common denominator with that is
transparency right it's uh
and it's also balanced and knowing that
you know
i am a musical superstar a grammy
award-winning but i also have a family
but i also have really good ideas that
need to get fleshed out so it's being
able to balance a lot of those things be
transparent and also being someone that
you know stays grounded stays humble and
continues to give back to the community
i know nfts are part of this deal two
chains break some news for me here you
release your album cover art this week i
mean are you going to be auctioning that
off as an nft are there any other nft
plans coming up for you listen listen i
have an album coming out 2-4
and it's called dope don't sell it but i
tell everybody if they substitute the
word dope for ideas that's what this
album means you can't sit back with a
good idea and think it's going to sell
itself a market itself and that's what
jc and i are doing i have really good
ideas that i'm going to bring to the
table and one of them is yeah the album
cover that i put out it looks like an
nft we have to be able to capture lives
off some of these images moving forward
all right all right i'll take that as a
soft nft there
jonathan going to you like we're talking
about right nft's merch this is all part
of your partnership
where do you see branding and kind of
this new revenue stream going what
excites you most here do you think it's
going to be crypto is it going to be the
metaverse is it going to be just regular
old merch look i think i think it's
probably all of the above and i think
the the restaurant business sometimes
has been a little bit slow to adapt to
this you've seen other big
consumer
industries particularly in footwear and
sportswear move quickly into this front
um i think you're what you're seeing is
is
restaurants being pulled forward and we
certainly want to be at the forefront of
that thus our partnership with chains
jonathan i got to ask you about these
food prices fast food prices up 8 over
the course of 2021 how concerned are you
about that and and that potentially
alienating customers
i mean we're seeing commodity prices
continue to increase i do think we'll
see you know ideally some of the
forecasts we're seeing
do show some flattening um
but it's definitely a real issue uh two
chains i want to go to you as well i
mean given those food prices are you
concerned at all about fans being able
to like follow you along and and support
your role at crystal by shopping at this
restaurant and buying food there no i
think i would bring something unique to
the space as far as you know redesigning
some of these structures as far as
enhancing the menu so i'm looking
forward to actually bringing in
uh more people with that type of
curiosity and i know that you grew up
going to uh this restaurant as well can
you tell me the weirdest quirkiest
memory you have of going to crystal
growing up i remember going to crystals
years ago
and and going to the drive-thru
and the person in front of us
fell asleep
in the car and it was like
you know we didn't realize it for the
longest like man this is taking forever
man what's going on and then we realized
that the person
you know had dozed off behind the wheel
so that's something that just really
sticks out of my mind on how we were
just like man
no get out of here you know what i'm
saying you holding us up jonathan what
about you what's a favorite memory you
have of crystal
yeah i was hoping i was gonna get the
answer that one too
um
i think probably the fondest memory or
the most memorable one i've got is is
eating 24 of these things in one night
um
it was
hasn't been there man i get it
yeah it's not uncommon to have a crystal
eating contest back in the day and
um
i haven't haven't engaged in taking down
24 of them lately however i have had my
share and um we'll see if anybody else
can beat that number out there i love it
i'm from florida so i understand the
importance of this establishment but i'm
in new york now i mean do you anticipate
expansion into the northeast moving
ahead and bringing this brand into new
york anytime soon
oh yeah for sure i mean
just before our call here i was looking
at uh some of the maps of where we're
expanding we we recently announced a
partnership with victor cruz to um to
bring crystal into the northeast
um
we're gonna be opening up to five stores
in in new jersey with him in i mean in
the immediate future um we're actively
looking at sites right now
look this brand can travel okay it's got
it's four different occasions it's
breakfast lunch dinner and then late
night as chains was referencing earlier
um
there are over 4 000 markets that we can
expand this brand into yeah well if you
could try to open one in the midtown
east area in manhattan as a first step i
would appreciate that so just whatever
you can do to make that business
opportunity work that would be great for
me uh two chains i want to ask you one
final question before we let you all go
obviously you are an investor and
entrepreneur in your own right when you
think about crypto nfts the metaverse
what is most exciting to you where do
you see yourself putting your efforts
into most moving forward
uh
fortunately for me i was blessed to
actually perform uh went to the
meadowbirds and i saw myself performing
so
i'm intrigued about i would call it the
future but i'm intrigued by the now
because we're literally in the future
right now and just knowing
that uh
you know in a few years you know
currency or cash as we know it won't
have as much meaning and
losing meaning now
understanding that nfts create so many
opportunities
for generational wealth
understanding what the metaverse is and
what the sandbox is and also
creating your own space within the
metabours and knowing that this was what
web 3 looks like this is what you know
the other chapter looks like i'm just
blessed to be a part of it um i'm
excited to be a part of it and i'm also
excited to use all of those things
in all of my businesses to create
different synergies and different
relationships
so it sounds like you see nfts as a
potential
future move and hedge against the
inequality that we're seeing in america
definitely